was weird with these guys with the you
know in a way on our show all the people
who work for us become minor celebrities
and then ma'amed I don't know how many
people follow him but he did this whole
thing online to get people to vote for
him to have a beaver named after my met
the zoo was naming seven beavers and a
long story even longer
it was odd to me because it would have
been funnier if he used the social media
to get a beaver to be named after Gary
cuz Gary looks like a bee right like
that might have been good for the show
instead he got he did get the beaver
named ma'amed he did which is completely
unfunny and nobody gives a [ __ ] right
mmmm explain your bit to me why can't I
be a cool guy
it wasn't my bed those were just my fans
who happen or fans
those are my fans understand yes your
fans yes but I have a small following on
Twitter and they alerted me to the fact
that they had decided to name this no
you decided it you decide no no no
that's not true I the Gary thing I
that's funny I would have done that but
the people wanted to be named because
you put up a post saying for some reason
people named a beer after me but then I
heard that you weren't reddit which are
not supposed to be on and that you saw
this whole thing going on and you that's
not your tell the truth someone tweeted
they said they alerted me to the fact
that someone had nominated my name is
this even interesting yeah to me it is
because why didn't you what was the zoo
that had a beaver Pittsburgh Pittsburgh
Zoo yeah
would it be funny to get the beaver name
bababooey cuz he's got beaver teeth yes
so be mad at the people who nominated
the names I agree yes I'm mad and the
people who nominated the names yes I
didn't I wasn't I could have you could
have gotten your fans to vote for Baba
Booey I was told that you saw that you
were nominated that you tweeted out to
everybody vote for me but you do know
why you want well I don't know why
you're hating write it anyway I thought
we decided you were to sense when
tweeted me about that and then you
yes we did decided you started crying
one time on the air and we decided the
best way for you to cope with all of the
pressure of social media is not for you
to read reddit I did and if my use of
Reddit okay anyways yes I'm sorry I blew
it once again yes you blew it I'm gonna
read you I'm in that tweet please vote
this is very important to me and my
family oh my god
sarcastic that's why I didn't think blue
you blew it you'll blow it right Fred
you'll blow it
Fred you'll blow it that's my answer you
better with him I honestly I thought
Gary would be upset that they didn't
name the beaver after him so I thought
it's kind of a win for me that they
named it after me oh you like it when
they not drop your name and all that
stuff I'm looking for a [ __ ] beaver
to be named after me I'm telling you
that right now that'd be very sincere I
would have been funny cuz Gary doesn't
want a beaver named after him all right
yeah not funny cuz you want it with the
power I am calling on the Pittsburgh Zoo
to change the name